[Musique]
waouh d'être super impressionnant
alors peut-être que je vais mettre à
rougir avant la voix qui tremble
peut-être même avoir des trous de
mémoire c'est normal
alors vous avez peut-être trouvé ça un
petit peu étrange pour un ancien sapeur
pompier de paris
pour un ancien sportif de haut niveau
thérapeute depuis presque dix ans et qui
accompagne et des dizaines de personnes
à gérer leurs peurs et leurs angoisses
avec plein d'outils comme l'hypnose le
modèle de palo alto a pnl et bien
d'autres choses
alors comment fait-on pour apprendre à
gérer ses angoisses
comment fait-on pour avoir le sentiment
d'avoir le contrôle de nous-mêmes pour
avoir confiance en soi
malheureusement la réalité quand on est
anxieux elle est bien différente
sont toujours les mêmes angoisses qui
reviennent encore et encore
n'arrête pas de ressasser de ruminer on
se pose toujours les mêmes questions
dans la beauce et de les faire taire de
penser à autre chose et pourtant leur
reviennent sans cesse comme une
obsession
est-ce que parmi vous déjà qu'ils ont
déjà ressenti cette étape d'être à main
levée
ok alors l'idée aujourd'hui c'est que
vous puissiez repartir on comprend mieux
en comprenant mieux le fonctionnement de
la peur mais surtout en ayant trois clés
pour vous aider à vaincre
dans mon cabinet pour accompagner mes
clients à gérer leurs peurs et leurs
angoisses j'utilise notamment la proche
de palo alto
et avant ça on va déjà essayer de
comprendre qu'est ce que c'est que la
peur alors déjà la peur si on prend la
définition du larousse c'est un
sentiment d'angoissé et prouver à la
présence soit la pensée dans des jets
d'un danger réel ou supposé
ok très bien mais concrètement qu'est ce
qui se passe dans notre cerveau en fait
lorsque l'un de nos sens détecte quelque
chose de suspect il envoie un signal à
la mygale
elles par des projections neuronale va
envoyer ainsi yann sur le tronc cérébral
qui va activer différents noyaux qui
vont activer toutes ces
qui va activer toutes les réactions
physiologiques et c'est pour cette
raison que sous influence du système
nerveux parasympathique
notre respiration s'arrête notre rythme
cardiaque ralentit et nous restons
tétanisé devant le danger potentiel
alors simplement à ce moment là le
cortex l'interview il à l'avenir il
analyse la situation et nous amène soit
à l'affronter soit fuir ok
donc tout simplement la peur un signal
que nous envoie nos cerveaux pour me
direz attention danger le but premier
n'est pas de la faire disparaître
complètement nos contraire d'en faire un
moteur une protection
comme je le disais notamment la peur
c'est
comme ça que je le travaille dans mon
cabinet j'utilise la proche de palo alto
donc la proche de palo alto
qu'est ce que c'est déjà la proche de
palo alto c'est sur laquelle se
construit l approche systémique et
stratégiques c'est une approche qui est
non normatives et non pathologie zante
ne cherche pas les solutions dans les
causes liées au passé mais se concentre
sur ce qui se passe ici et maintenant
le mental recherche institué mais l'idée
que selon laquelle un problème n'existe
pas en soi mais que la façon dont nous
réagissons aux problèmes de la vie
peuvent amener celle ci à devenir une
réalité
paul watzlawick l'un des pères
fondateurs
de l'école de palo alto disait cette
formule le célèbre paradoxal le problème
c'est la solution
alors
simplement
avant ça on va prendre exemple au promu
expliqué je vais prendre un exemple le
mien comment gérer ma peur de parler en
public pendant cette conférence la
première chose à faire est donc
d'analyser mes tentatives de solutions
dysfonctionnelle pour gérer mes peurs
alors lorsqu'on m'a appris pour cette
conférence tedx la première chose est
d'avoir ressenti de la joie l'excitation
et puis très vite j'ai commencé à voir
mes premières kraft qu'est ce que tu
peux raconter il faut faire quelque
chose d'intéressant
faut que ça plaise aux autres
et puis très vite ces craintes ont
commencé à se transforme en non gaap
alors j'ai commencé c'est de me rassurer
nous étendre n'inquiète pas s'être tu
vas faire un truc super tu en es capable
a déjà fait plein de conférence
je vais peut-être même avoir une
standing ovation à la fin mai valait
compris ça n'a pas vraiment fonctionné
amber ont continué de grandir
alors
simplement la peur elle n'est pas très
apprécié des êtres humains qui la
plupart du temps la considère comme une
sensation qu'il faut craindre
une faiblesse à éviter
c'est pour ça que le premier réflexe
quand on a une peur une angoisse peut
avoir tendance à vouloir essayer de la
faire taire la retenir la garder à
l'intérieur de soi et pourtant
inexorablement celle ci ne fait que
s'exacerber
la peur si on l'encouragé lieu de la
fuir ou la réprimer va se saturer par
ses propres excès
et assez paradoxalement le fait de faire
cet exercice m'a rendu plus serein
ça m'a amené à affronter ma peur ça m'a
rendu plus fort
alors c'était très bien j'avais pu gérer
mes peurs avant la conférence
et maintenant comment gérer ma peur
pendant la conférence
comme vous l'a dit tout à l'heure ma
peur était d'avoir des réactions
physiologiques avoir la voix qui tremble
les trous de mémoire peut-être même de
rougir
et si on suit le modèle de palo alto
l'idée c'est d'essayer de ne pas
contrôler ses réactions physiologiques
souvenez vous des premières phrases
cette conférence waouh le super
impressionnant peut-être que je me
mettre à trembler à rougir même avoir
des trous de mémoire
je vous ai déclaré mon secret honteux
c'est ma deuxième clé c'est à dire que
j'ai annoncé ce qui me faisait peur et
le fait d'annoncer ce qui fait peur
permet de s'en libérer permet d'arrêter
d'essayer de le contrôler et nous amène
à nous apaiser là nous en libérer alors
je vous invite simplement a déclaré
votre petit secret honteux montrer jour
après jour une petite faiblesse
qui vous emprisonnent dans la peur cela
vous permet de vous en libérer
et de vous sentir plus fort et plus
serein
enfin je termine avec une troisième clé
n'est pas vraiment une clé mais qui est
plutôt une erreur qui font la plupart
des jeux qui sont les gens qui sont
stressés ou anxieux fait la tentative
d'éviter aux de fuir ce qui fait peur ou
la danse ou la demande d aide à un ami
alors lorsqu on fait ça on rentre dans
une stratégie d'évitement alors
forcément à court terme bas ça nous
amène une sensation de bien-être on sent
apaisé
puis à court et moyen terme forcément va
ressentir d'insatisfaction et puis du
regret
et puis à long terme ça va générer
encore plus accepter ça va amplifier
l'évitement et ça va générer encore plus
dans satisfaction
stratégie serait alors
la stratégie d'exposition au risque
c'est-à-dire
sur du court terme qu'est ce que ça va
mener forcément une certaine
appréhension un certain inconfort le
fait de pouvoir se confronter à sa peur
court et moyen terme ça va emmener
forcément de la satisfaction de bonne
estime de soi et puis sur du long terme
ça va amener la confiance sur soi la
sérénité et se permet de nous sentir
plus serein grâce à l'apprentissage
alors je vous invite à observer dans
votre quotidien
toutes les fois où à cause d'une peur
vous ne faites pas vous ne dites pas
vous faites ou vous dit certaines choses
de peur de ce qui pourrait se passer de
peur des conséquences si c'est justifié
ok mais si ça ne l'est pas il est juste
conscience qu'à chaque fois que vous
faites ça vous est juste en train de
vous renfermez dans votre cercle vicieux
d'alimenter votre peur
alors simplement aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous dire un grand merci
parce que ce soir vient d'affronter mes
peurs ai jamais parlé devant autant de
personnes du coup je me sens beaucoup
plus serein beaucoup plus de confiance
en moi et j'aimerais juste que vous
rappelez d'une chose la seule et unique
façon vous débarrasser d'une peur de
l'affronter merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m